this year the average American will
spend nearly 600 on gift cards more than
all other gifts combined
naturally a few of those 198 billion
dollars will go unused cards get lost in
the couch forgotten entirely or a few
pennies here and there left as remainder
individually these Financial leftovers
are insignificant
but collectively they add up
Starbucks now is much a bank as a coffee
shop held 181 million dollars worth of
stored credit in 2021.
and when Radio Shack declared bankruptcy
it reported 46 million dollars worth of
unredeemed gift cards
where does all that money go
Common Sense would say the company's
pockets of course why else would gift
cards be placed in prominent high
traffic parts of the store
but not necessarily
quite often unused gift cards are
commandeered by the state
and not just any state
not as you might reasonably assume the
state where the card was purchased
nor even the home state of its buyer
in reality a significant portion of all
unclaimed gift cards across the entire
United States regardless of where they
were purchased are seized by just one
state the second smallest state in fact
Delaware
and its tiny population of one million
profits enormously
Delaware is one of five states with no
sales tax along with Alaska Oregon
Montana and New Hampshire
it also has one of the lowest property
taxes in the country
yet despite collecting lower overall
taxes than any state except a
resource-rich Alaska Delaware spends
more per capita than all but three
others
in other words Delaware operates in many
ways like a tiny profit-seeking rent
maximizing oil-rich Emirates
rather than being blessed with a natural
resource like oil it's been granted the
near exclusive legal right to collect
many of America's unused gift cards
foreign
sponsored by nebula the exclusive home
to my original series China actually
Delaware is not the only place that
seizes unclaimed property all 50 states
have laws of this variety
when someone dies without errors for
instance the state takes custody of
their home
if no rightful owner is found it's sold
and the proceeds redistributed to the
public
but this process called achievement was
envisioned with physical property in
mind
as wealth became increasingly intangible
things got complicated
in 1965 four different states tried to
claim the same undeposited paychecks
from Sun oil worth twenty six thousand
dollars
Texas where the checks were issued
conveniently argued the state which had
the most significant contacts with the
debt should receive them
New Jersey with a company was legally
Incorporated argued it was entitled to
the prophets
because Sun oil was headquartered in
Pennsylvania it too made a play for the
money as the debtors principal place of
business
finally Florida's claim was based on the
last known address of the paycheck
recipients
the Supreme Court was charged with
deciding which of these rules to
sanctify with its gavel and pretend
wasn't as arbitrary as the next
in the end the court did what courts are
good at concealing the arbitrary nature
of its ruling with complexity
the fewest solution it said would be a
compromise
first unclaimed property would be
assigned based as Florida suggested on
the recipient's last known address
in the unlikely event none could be
found it would simply revert to where
the company was incorporated in this
case New Jersey
but what the court failed to anticipate
was the Monumental rise of gift cards
almost by definition no one knows the
last known address of the owner of a
gift card
after all most gift cards are gifted to
someone else
in practice therefore unused gift cards
almost always belong to the state in
which the company is registered and that
state is almost always Delaware
this is the number of Fortune 500
companies registered in each state as of
2018.
Virginia has 11 Ohio 16 and New York 20.
now watch what happens when we add
Delaware at well over 300.
Delaware is to corporations what Liberia
Panama and the Marshall Islands are to
ships
the only difference is that Liberia
Panama and the Marshall Islands have
competition
whereas 95 percent of businesses that
incorporate outside their home state
choose Delaware
the first and most obvious reason is
money
Delaware doesn't tax intangible
Investments like trademarks and patents
allowing companies to transfer their
mascots logos and Jingles to the state
and save Millions
the second is speed
an interaction with the Delaware
Division of Corporations would blow the
mind of anyone with a misfortune of
having visited a DMV
if you're willing to pay extra you can
form your company in less than 30
minutes and its offices stay open until
midnight making life easy for anyone in
Dubai Lagos or Hong Kong
then there's the extreme anonymity
you don't need to prove your identity to
register a business in Delaware
in fact you don't have to provide your
name address or phone number
all the state requires is a single
contact person who can be anyone 18 or
older who lives on planet Earth whether
or not they're a U.S citizen or even
live in the country
in theory any state in the Union could
offer companies anonymity speed and low
taxes
but there's one thing only Delaware has
decades and Decades of legal precedent
the United States inherited from England
two types of Courts common law and
Chancery the latter of which dealt with
issues of fairness especially in the
realm of property
since then Most states have merged the
two into one Superior Court except three
Tennessee Mississippi and Delaware
today the Delaware Chancery Court is
effectively a separate justice system
for corporations
instead of erratic juries its decisions
are made by specialized judges who've
seen thousands of similar cases
in other words corporations choose
Delaware for its predictability
now it may sound like the state of
Delaware is effectively colluding with
corporate America
but not exactly
sure Delaware fights hard to attract
companies
but at the same time it's hardly any
less profit oriented than they are
once they've set up shop it extracts
from them every last penny it can
needless to say this near Monopoly on
corporate registration is
extraordinarily profitable
it collects more in corporate fees alone
than 42 States collect in corporate
income taxes
but the state of Delaware is far from
satisfied it wants more
and that puts it on a collision course
with nearly everyone else
take gift cards for instance
Delaware interprets the 1965 Supreme
Court ruling as a license to collect
virtually all of America's unused gift
cards
and it will aggressively fight any
company or even government that stands
in his way
remember the purpose of a sheetment is
first and foremost to reunite Lost
Property with its owner
the state is a mere custodian until a
rightful Heir is found
because it's nearly impossible to track
down the rightful error of a gift card
many states have quite sensibly Exempted
them
but it doesn't matter Delaware still
claims that money as its own even when
the company in question has not a single
office employee or customer within its
borders
in other words the states of California
Texas and New York for example can't
decide what happens to the unused gift
cards sold in their own territory
it's as if Delaware could impose an
extra territorial income tax on
residents of Nevada where there isn't
one
its motive of course is revenue lots of
it in 2001 the state discovered that
less than one percent of companies had
reported unclaimed property and decided
to crack down it outsourced the
enforcement of this Arcane law to four
auditing firms
these Auditors in turn would reach out
to companies with a wildly High estimate
of what they owed
if the company couldn't disprove this
enormous number with 20 years worth of
documentation it would be forced to
cough up the money
while the state of Washington keeps its
unclaimed property forever and even has
a staff of people searching for its
rightful owner only about two percent is
ever returned in Delaware
the rest it simply spends
unclaimed property is Delaware's third
largest source of Revenue behind only
personal income taxes and corporate fees
in 2016 a federal judge ruled that the
state of Delaware was quote engaged in a
game of gotcha that shocks the
conscience
the victims in this game are not only
corporations but the entire United
States
by delegating to States the power to
register corporations with no minimum
standards the U.S federal government
Unleashed a race to the bottom
a race that would ultimately benefit one
state to the detriment of all others
then in 1965 the Supreme Court further
tipped the scales in Delaware's favor by
unintentionally granting it a virtual
monopoly on unclaimed corporate property
recall that its rationale at the time
was fairness to every state the court
didn't foresee how Delaware would
weaponize its ruling
and that's how we got here
today a State home to just 0.3 percent
of the U.S population effectively sets
U.S corporate law
a power it used to propel the country to
number one on the financial secrecy
index above Switzerland Luxembourg and
the British Virgin Islands
thanks to Delaware the United States of
America may be the best place to launder
money
Victor bout one of the world's most
notorious arms traffickers and
inspiration for the 2005 film Lord of
War set up dozens of shell companies in
Delaware
the state became a sanctuary for the
profits he made selling weapons used in
Wars throughout Afghanistan Iran and
Syria years long an absolutely brutal
conflicts which remain poorly understood
today
and modern conflicts a nearly 30 episode
nebula original series by real life lore
traces each of these wars from their
very Inception to the present day
telling stories that could only be told
on an independent platform like nebula
free from the threat of demonetization
thanks to the creative freedom offered
by nebula Neo was able to make this
investigation into flight mh17 tech
alter this critical look at how 911
changed Cinema and me this deeper look
at how China Works by subscribing to
nebula you not only get all these great
original series but you also get access
to nebula classes for no extra cost or
you can take a behind the scenes look at
your favorite creators there are no ads
or sponsors and many videos are
available early if you sign up today you
can get nebula for 40 off with the
annual plan that's just two dollars and
fifty cents a month for both nebula and
nebula classes with a link on screen or
in the description